[Applause]
[Music]
what's up
everybody welcome to cooking with
pewdiepie
today we're making connecticut
[Music]
all right can't get bright i don't know
what i call it it's like an american way
kinect bread is what i'm making
it's a classic it's the best bread of
all
time it's good for your digestion it
gets hella business
what more do i need to say about
connective breath you ain't swedish
if you don't have knicker bro that's
just a fact uh
i never actually made kinky bro and
that's the problem because here in this
country they don't sell good kaneki bro
i cannot find good connective bra oh
clicky bro you mean rye bread felix i
had that no
that's not crooked bruh that's fake fake
bro
so i'm gonna try and make it i have
never made bread in my entire life
how hard can it be right it says it
takes
nine hours that's fine
what takes 45 minutes to prep
what the [ __ ] is this oh it it oh and
the dough has to sit for eight hours no
problem
so what you need to make bro is dark rye
flour
whole spelt flour i don't know what this
is fast action yeast
yes get it get it kids you understand
and
sea salt all right where do i start
combine the two
flowers but there's three flowers okay
yeah yeah
this is what the vikings used to do you
know i bet i bet you have cringey white
flower well in sweden we have epic dark
flower
because it's dark like evil
like dark side flower conical
200 grams of connective brood
oh my god guys i am so strong i
bent the whole thing too much power
all right that's 250. then i need
another 50. i'll try not to break
martia's
equipment boy
all right then we add 100 gram of uh
cringe spelt flour
what even is that who thinks in their
spare time
hey what if i combine different flowers
cringe 100 gram
boost connect
cricket connect it click it
kick it i wish i had my tambourine
i'm also supposed to add the yeast one
teaspoon of yeast
[Music]
oh one half teaspoon almost mess that up
crunch that would have been cringe
that would have been almost as bad as
trying a 700
whiskey and still get it the answer
wrong why am i so bright
all right next up i add the water water
200 milliliters
actually let me add my expensive
wasp water yes i drink wasp it's
whatever
now i work it until smooth this smells
nice
this smells like a child i think i need
more water
god damn it more boss
is it supposed to be this firm it's like
really sticky is it too much too little
water or
is it too epic maybe it's supposed to be
like that does it not have pictures
no pictures we're making clicky blocks
no step by step dude
yeah that would have been helpful hey
catch guys
we're ready to attach it you're gonna
get you want to get you
connected oh
that is good that tastes like 700.
i can tell the difference
if it seems too dry add a little more
water a teaspoon at a time
work until it's smooth it's supposed to
be smooth
what does smooth mean
what is smooth in italian leash
well then why did you say it do you not
know your language
what is smooth in swedish
am i supposed to add the salt i forgot
the salt mars there here
here here it's
i'm burning up i need a six gram
put it on the concrete well done
you are an angel
i think i had whiskey before this video
all right it looks like this now
so good all right so this is how it
looked like
so it's gonna sit in eight hours what
time will eight hours be from now
it's three guess we're doing late
cooking huh oh god i don't want to cook
at 11
i did not think this through yes yeah
okay connect your bra step one complete
see you in eight
hours eight hours late there it's 11.
we're making clicky bruh what was i
thinking doing this
like not not at all i was not thinking
at all
but here we have the big reveal
what do you think huh
looks good i'm a bit insecure tell me it
looks good
thank you it swelled up a bit
i read it said it would swell up a bit
it swell up a bit
it smells yeah so now i'm supposed to
make
24 chop chop pieces
the dough into 24 25 grams each
shape into a bowl place on well floured
work
place use rye flour roll out as thin as
you can
hey welcome to pewdiepie bakes bread and
i love connective right if this actually
i was thinking if this works out well
oh wait what's the mean
is that is that the meme did i do it
kids what it's for salt
what it's not for flowers yeah but i'm
swedish
i do flower dark flower the evilest
flower of the monk
do not tempting it is doing
i married a savage so a ball
right boom
24 balls that's a lot of bottles well i
know how to make meatballs
so i know how to make these balls you
impressed so far
to have them all equal usually you pre
like you
you can divide the huh not all balls are
made equal might be
if i even know this there's it's still
quite sticky
i wonder if i didn't use enough uh
everything
i'm screwed what am i doing why am i
doing something i don't know how to do
i'm a failure guys no don't give up
felix
okay cool up
shut up i don't need this
oh no no listen
sometimes you may connect your bra
sometimes
you [ __ ] it all up i don't know
i'm not giving up but they're going to
be flattened anyway right
maybe you want them to be eaten why all
right i don't know
then why are you even bothering
oh so you give up now so you give up
before i give up
i never give up on cracker bruh can i
compress my life
this is like making what's the most
important thing for you
pasta is like making pasta do you
understand how i performed
this all right i'm kind of giving up on
that one
i just want it to be good i just want
people to look at me and say hey
it looks good
i don't want people to look at me like
oh he's a screaming youtube guy i want
people to look at me and say hey
he's a chef he's the guy that makes the
clicky bro
just for the record i never made bread
in my life just to wear clear i made
bagels once and they were not pretty let
me tell you
they look more like snakes in the grass
all right if you're a bread maker
and you're watching this video can you
cut me some slack
can you just be like all right for the
first try at least he's not bad or
something
what do you think listen now that was a
knot yeah
sideways not are you feeling your
favorite the wrong way marcia
all right i need more i need more [ __ ]
they they she actually did say
well flowered right oh my god it's so
much easier man
all right that's 24 pieces right one two
one two three that seems about right
this one is for you marzia because it's
tiny and cute
yeah that's how you get a wifey
let's get that julian solomita type of
action
yeah julian all right he can help you
with all due respect he's not a chef
either
so that does not make me look good right
now don't compare me to julian
because he cooks well yeah yeah all
right
good
julian i challenge you to make better
connect your breath because you can
listen when i get insecure i get
aggressive i'm sorry i apologize
don't cancel me the almonds are on i
didn't forget that
i think that's a plus one two five one
one to two millimeters
and then prickle them with a fork i'm
supposed to place them on a hot tray do
we have hot springs in there
no i mean just um don't we have regular
trays yeah
not here how am i supposed to make
makeup bruh
all right i'm just going with it so the
first ball
is definitely the most important one and
you don't want to miss that
so make sure you flour the
what is this called rolling pin rolling
paint
that looks pretty good
why does it keep sticking all right
screw this
that's your connector bro that's a
goddamn connector bro right there these
are
mini kanekamra uh they're actually
famous in
different areas in sweden we're doing it
live we're doing a alive it's me
look how bad he is you can't mess up
flowers how do you mess up flower felix
i don't know humbling moment for me
did that why are they so sticky like did
i what did i do wrong
stop they're beautiful
look it will come off it will come up
five percent
butter 100 flour
and then more flour all right that's too
connected bruh
is that a win this is a dad moment
what do you think what are your
expectations here's the marzipan
why are you laughing working why were
you laughing
yeah i didn't ask you to laugh for me
[Music]
the thing is like i was actually excited
10 minutes ago because i thought oh like
if this is easy to do i can just make my
own connector brandon be like that guy
that makes his own connecting breath
i'll never be that guy oh we know we
don't know
we don't know right we don't know remove
the trays
place the crisp bed on a hot tray oh
it's hot
bake for eight to ten minutes until they
are lightly browned
oh of course we're gonna fork the
connective brand so it looks like
kaneki bro you know what i mean you know
what i'm saying
now it looks like nicki bryant that one
i don't know
let's pretend edit sorry edit that i
want to look like knickerbocker
oh yeah so i was like what the [ __ ] is
gonna give it
how would you make 24 out of that wow
make 24 pieces out of them
this is what defeated looks like but i'm
not
giving up yet all right what was it here
all right i'm getting my dad win
excuse me oh now i can be the meme
oh he's got that weird like down
is that it okay am i in a meme boom
eight minutes y'all laughing now but in
eight minutes
pop that baby in the oven dude i see you
in eight minutes
what the oven is not on
i'm getting help from pasta lady
on patch too that looks good i got such
good hat all right so this is how you
hit it i mean
i got such good technique
oh okay it's done you hear that okay
let's check them out they don't really
look then
damn what the top ones the bottom
oh no it's
okay i got all right all right okay
they smell amazing but they're not done
they're not done before you judge
they're not done they have to cook for
20 more minutes
that's pretty good right
no all right they're not good fine
they're not good they're not good okay
but they will be
trust me smell good though
i got that was that you shake no to me
what the hell
oh that's right oh
okay i i'm starting to get the whole
bread
mean you know smells good it smells
fresh
and all right
so now the manual says he was gonna
cook them as a tower don't do it don't
do this by the way i know this is down
should i just throw this away this isn't
bad on the bottom
all right so they're still soft
but we're gonna cook them for another 20
after the other batch is done
batching baby that's what it's all about
we drop ship
thing shipping we out here subscribe for
more
cooking videos you want my cf yours is a
little better just a little
the oh these are thin as well how are
you so good
oh your heart kind of sucks cause you've
made it
a minute into a heart oh this looks
actually really good
i think i made one two three i'm glad
you helped me actually
[Applause]
now these cook for 20 minutes
that's not fit i didn't think it through
now we want it refuses
to become connected you will become
gangnam bro
but i'll come to the tower i don't know
what happened
see you in 20 minutes boy
[Music]
20 minutes later i i'm so sorry
i hope this was worth birthday but here
they are
they smell really good they maybe don't
look the best
but they smell oh they don't look good
in this line all right let's see
that yes they're hard
maybe a little soft but that's fine i'll
take it at this point
i'm thrilled all things considered
do you want some go with these yeah
and i'll eat the monster don't worry did
i get a thin one
yeah okay chicken broth
well if you're making bread
make sure you have a lot of time oh it
melts
oh that's nice usually in sweden we put
the [ __ ]
out you know what i talked about last
time it's this spice
in school they always have it they
always have it
and you put it on top of your
connecticut bra i don't have it the main
you got a good shot here we go
so it's a little chewy
i only just wanted to be chewy but it's
pretty good
yeah oh
the egg is really good i think you might
put them a little longer than average
meal
the seasonal on top is a good idea all
right
it tastes like making brown
holy [ __ ] i'm not eating that
sorry but you're dead probably
i'm so happy all right thanks for
watching
cooking with pewdiepie boy oh boy was
just an adventure
let me know what you want to see next
smash like subscribe we're trying to hit
107 million
oh remind you someone
check it out link in description ah
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
hoopty is coming to
nintendo's switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]
we